on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
I'm Jeremy Carl I'm Piers Morgan
uncensored and coming up on tonight's
program
missing in action with the bank of
England forced to step in to prevent
economic catastrophe we ask the simple
question where is our new prime minister
as trust economics continues to crash
the pound
with interest rates expected to Peak as
high as six percent UK lenders are
halting hundreds of mortgage deals
leading first time buyers stranded and
thousands unable to afford their
repayments is that a U-turn we see on
the horizon I wonder why
and has Strictly Come Dancing become the
BBC's latest woke box ticking exercise
tonight some of its former stars and why
it's clear the show now values inclusion
over entertainment
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Jeremy Kyle good evening
my friends from London this is Piers
Morgan I'm sensed I'm still Jeremy Carl
back for two days only not of course by
popular demand but because his lordship
decided that he wanted to go to Scotland
and play golf now I had two options I
could follow him to Scotland presumably
in a lorry and search for his balls
inside High rough in a rainy and windy
Scottish golf course and end up looking
like that idiot over there
or I could sit here in a warm and dry
studio and talk to you about things that
frankly really matter what did I decide
yes I wanted to ask you this tonight
what do you think the last few days have
meant we were promised were we not a tax
cutting mini budget that would Herald a
new era for Britain it's a new era right
just one that none of us wanted or
frankly even begin to understand I like
you thought things couldn't get any
worse with this cost of living crisis
how wrong we were trust and quateng have
managed to create their own financial
crisis which is some achievement given
they've only been 22 days in the job
today The Spectator sums up the new pm
and Chancellor quite nicely there
incompetence would be laughable they say
if it wasn't so serious today the bank
of England had to step into car markets
that haven't been this volatile since
the financial crisis of 2008. we hear
the pound has tumbled to an all-time low
against the dollar but you know what it
would be easy to make it all about
markets wouldn't in economics and
bankers for me let's talk about the Imp
impact on you have you got a mortgage do
you know that your repayments could go
up by more than 300 quid a month on a
200 000 pound mortgage maybe you're
renting because you can't afford to go
on the ladder payments will then rise as
well because landlords will struggle to
absorb Sky High mortgage costs add into
that pensions petrol food energy
everything right nobody it seems will be
immune from this Almighty [ __ ] up Tory
MPS we hear already after 22 days
putting in letters of no confidence in
trust and who can blame them and best of
all labor rubbing their hands with Glee
if they had planned this they couldn't
have done a better job themselves they
will up week from what we hear they
could march to power quite quietly right
without even saying anything but
whatever happens my friends one thing is
for sure it will be you it will be me it
will be all of us who will be paying the
price so we're going to start tonight's
the first time in a while it's a warm
welcome to Jesus journals uh my good
friend uh it says here talk TV Legend
Richard Tice
uh political commentator Marina perk is
12 days from giving birth but still
proving she is desperate to be with me
and the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire been a while how are very
well very well are you all right I'm
absolutely fine well preparing today the
boys and I are quite worried can you
imagine if this happened
no sudden movements let's start with Liz
truss if we can Marina where is she she
tweeted five minutes ago by the way
congratulations to it Georgia Maloney on
her party success in the Italian
elections what about the disaster that's
befall in the United States yeah so
George is not a friend she's the door is
not out for Georgia no that even though
there are you know Mussolini sort of
Tendencies
Italian politics let's just say that in
22 days a night to be perfectly honest
was quite vocal about you know sunak
would never be trusted by the Tory
faithful because he was deemed as the
person that knife Boris Johnson what has
gone on
she's absolutely fluffed it 22 days in
and I don't know how she could have
actually done any worse we are basically
living in the petri dish of what is
um sort of Think Tank dreamer's dream so
you've got to bear in mind all of the
people that got Liz trusses here at the
moment come from these dodgily funded
think tanks like the The Institute of
economic Affairs for example got
somebody on that later oh well just
maybe ask them about their funding
because that's an interesting question
well you stay around
for me because they're not going to
shout at a pregnant woman
I mean honestly it's expenses it's not a
catastrophe and of course it's a double
whammy that people forget because on
Wednesday they announced they had to
have an energy price freeze they did it
completely the wrong way they ignored my
sound advice so they'll essentially put
another 100 to 150 billion quid on the
taxpayer and that's going to last six to
nine months the market knows that
Putin's gas Taps are turned off that's
now been sabotaged so that's going to
make that worse and then they cut the
wrong taxes it's right to go for growth
it's right to cut taxes for the lowest
paid the lease well off and for small
businesses they've done the opposite
it's an absolute catastrophe the markets
have realized it it's hard to know where
it goes from here uh but it's it's
incredibly incredibly bad and what's
happened today is the Bank of England
has to step in and buy bonds because the
pension markets are an absolute meltdown
through very complex reasons Kevin being
a world great to see you pal um just
back from the the labor Party Conference
um it it seems as an introduction the
the tourists have messed this up so
magnificently that labor could literally
I mean the latest opinion polls 17 17.
could just walk quietly to power without
saying anything they can't believe their
luck in truth and for labor to win the
Tories that conservatives the government
has to do badly and it is just screwed
up massively and a strong confident
leader will be out now explaining what
they did trying to reassure the markets
but let's trust has probably locked in a
bedroom with the curtains closed uh just
hiding hiding away it's absolutely
incredible she is not out fronting this
crisis and and you know we had all the
Boris stuff right a senior tour he said
today I thought the Boris Johnson's
government was a catastrophe the first
22 days are the worst ever this just in
from the government the government is
preparing plans for major cost cutting
across all departments to help balance
the budget I thought we were going to
buy I thought we were going to spend
billions more on the Armed Forces but if
they'd said that on Friday
the markets would actually have
understood it and look there's loads of
ways for government spending that should
be cut that's the way look every
householders look at the budget and say
I need to save 500. if the government
did the same to every manager of every
Department you say 50 billion Richard
I'm sorry we've just we're about to have
this bonfire of EU regulations
I know you're a fan but what do you
think that's going to do for Whitehall
resource do you think that's that's
really the time it means we can get rid
of a load of unnecessary civil
observance because they've got less
regulations
exactly yeah
can I ask you all a question right and
treat me like the idiot I am start with
you Kev right so the basis of what they
did last week was to infuse be it
Bankers or successful business people in
the major Financial cities of this
country to come here make money and that
would trickle down not something that
was going to happen overnight right
what they did was they cut tax on
anybody only over I think was 155 Grand
did nobody go on on a serious note and I
suppose you know in the past you'd say
is he a conservative probably what did
nobody go hold on a minute the people
the jams the just about managing those
people who are really really struggling
how in the name of God are these people
in the middle of a crisis that they
can't afford to pay almost anything how
are they going to react to the fact that
the richest are getting tax cuts and
we're not I don't get that yeah no it's
political suicide undoubtedly they did
not think it's through but it's driven
by Dogma they want and actually this is
where brexit was always intended to lead
for them to reduce the size of the state
to have lots of deregulation and cut tax
on the very richest well you do that
people are going to say it's
fundamentally unfair but the way they
did it they're increasing spending
reducing taxes the sums don't add up
it's not a Magic Money Tree it's a whole
Forest of them that have given a shake
so you can see why the rest of the world
is can I just say it is crazy it's the
reason I agree with him and you
surprised I'm saying that is you can't
expect the majority of working-class
people on people on Lower wages to
understand a government that says we're
cutting the conic Associates cutting the
taxes
it's worse than that because the
personal tax thresholds right at 12 and
a half Grand are frozen you've got give
or take 10 inflation so it's worse the
poor are getting poorer the low pay to
getting getting less well off and the
rich are getting richer I mean it is
political to us so this will be done in
the name of growth right and stimulating
the economy what do you think so for
example I've got people in my family
that get going to benefit from this cut
they aren't going to go and spend it in
the economy it's going to go in their
savings account so it's pointless which
will be all right with the interest rate
um Graham Brady allegedly today uh
already receiving letters of no
confidence Boris Johnson must be sitting
wherever he sat thinking
I mean honestly really strong and stable
strong and stable what are we going to
be on now as well so quasi-coating is
apparently toast that's what Tory
Minister has been saying so that's going
to be our
do not get the job
I'm very excited about it he's not going
to the conservative conference remember
he warned that it was fantasy economics
Michael Gove said you're taking a
holiday from reality
this is Narnia we are in knowledge we
could talk about this tonight final word
because I want to talk about it they
could have got away with it if they'd
cut taxes at the at the lowest end but
they haven't they haven't indicated
cutting spending they've come at you
like it look it's it's I don't know
where it goes Jeremy but it's bad I
quite agree um I saw something on
television this morning it ripped my
head to bits David Norris the man uh one
half of two violent criminals who killed
Stephen Lawrence uh taking a selfie in
his prison cell
um Xbox gold watch mobile phone what is
wrong with this country what is the
criminal justice system should be
completely reformed why is he allowed to
do that he murdered somebody
it's truly sickening it's appalling um
how does it happen with no idea how do
they get this stuff into into prisons is
it corruption is it incompetence but you
know he's apparently he's up for parole
in 2026 I think it is hopefully that
gets completely scrapped and yeah as you
say I mean there's something
fundamentally wrong with our justice
system when people like that uh can can
behave in the way that they have he's
not allowed to have the phone but he's
somehow got it now he can be they could
be snuggled into Kev well yeah well you
think for Doreen Lawrence whose son was
was murdered and there is this guy
taking selfies sending it to his mate
saying I'll be out in two
he should not be out in two he even said
he hasn't lost a wink of sleep or
something along those lines at all um
research for documentary our BBC News
readers to Posh BBC research found that
70 of news readers across the BBC ITV
Channel 4 on Sky News speak with Posh
received pronounce the ocean the Posh is
accent compared with 10 of the rest of
the population let's have a look at this
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the BBC News
at six this is BBC news with the latest
headlines good evening and welcome to
the BBC News at six this is BBC News
these are the latest headlines in the UK
and around the world good evening and
welcome to the BBC News at six
top TV
Richard have you got a job
it's ridiculous but the most ridiculous
thing is that they've got enough time
and money and resources to waste time
ridiculous I shouldn't be wasting my
money I think it's because people in
this country are deferential to people
with Posh accents and they believe them
look at the stuff that he comes out with
and people believe in because he's got a
project
[Laughter]
I'd rather hear that than a load of
poshies it's true um the BBC listed out
I bash the BBC every single day I think
you're quite right let's sum it up they
get their money without having to
justify it with audience figures or
anything at all and frankly at the end
of the day you're right we're spending
hundreds of thousands of pounds and
doing research into apparently the fact
that people shouldn't be surpass hang on
it it costs next to nothing but no
you've got it you've got it you've got
to know who you're recruiting to
therefore broaden it out if you're
getting too many of the rules
massive value for money if you consider
what you get from the BBC are you joking
are you joking rubbish man you don't
want the choice
I'm going to attempt to do this link as
a BBC person coming up tonight my
friends has the housing market become
the latest victim of trust knowledge and
is the king above the Lord what's wrong
with me a Scotland Yard steps up its
investigation to the cash for honors
Scandal embroiling our new king will the
police question the Monarch we're coming
right back in three don't go anywhere
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
s now with the Prime Minister and the
chancellor frankly missing in action and
the UK economy and life support the bank
of England have today stepped into calm
fears but spare a thought for those
trying to get a mortgage as the housing
market becomes frankly the latest victim
of trust economics now looking at this
right interest rates could Peak as high
as 6 six percent this time next year and
that will in real terms add hundreds of
pounds to monthly mortgage repayment at
the same time nearly four hundred
thousand households will be coming to
the end of their fixed rate mortgages
and if you're a first-time buyer trying
to get on this property letter it's
going to become virtually impossible to
find a mortgage as a growing list of
Banks and building societies pull
products from the market now joining me
now to try and make sense of what is
frankly chaotic is estate agent Tobias
Alexander Rose and the Chief Operating
Officer of The Institute of economic
Affairs Andy Mayer and Marina Perkins is
still with us I got here good evening
people Marina is still here Andy I'll
start with you um you're from The
Institute of economic Affairs a
right-wing think tank that presumably
supports what can only be described as a
political well somebody said no
political suicide what the heck is going
on man I don't understand it in real
terms can I just make it very simple
right
you're letting people on more money
off tax and you're not looking after the
people who are struggling in a cost of
living crisis and I would probably be a
small conservative can you explain to me
how you expect the British public to
swallow that pill because I don't
understand so few errors there the ia's
free market which includes views on the
left and the right right and but you
support this government policy right not
the entirety of it no the first thing
that happened with this government
package was the energy price guarantee
and we immediately issued a strong note
of concern that this was unfunded
borrowing but you support the tax cuts
so we support two things in the budget
one is cutting taxes not necessarily all
of the individual taxes and the way
they've been done but also the supply
side reforms which to be clear is really
important stuff like reducing planning
regulations
tax cut
in terms of it being on its own no in
terms of it being bringing tax level
back down to where labor had it for the
entirety of their time in office by the
last year it's not an unreasonable thing
to do but the timing of it seems to be
mischarged when you say it's not an
unreasonable thing to do and a marina
will take a breath because she's 12 days
from giving birth and I'm slightly
worried about the whole thing
um do you imagine that that what I would
call normal working-class people people
who are struggling to put food on the
table when they've paid all the bills
they're not on Universal Credit they're
not on benefits they're jams just about
managing right do you honestly imagine
that they are going to look at this and
think this government gives the damn
about us because I understand about let
the money trickle down but short term
this is this this is the point Andy I
don't think people get people are really
struggling and they don't think this
government has got a clue so one thing
the government could have done which we
thought they were going to do but they
didn't was cut vat which would have
helped a lot more people another thing
they could have done was reverse this
freezing allow ounces that Rishi sunat
brought in which will then have helped
everybody the income tax cut does help
most people particularly those on Lower
incomes the changes to National
Insurance as in not raising them that
should help more people as well so the
distributional impact has been
exaggerated by the one big mistake they
made on the 45p rate but across the
board they were trying to do that and we
would expect to see more of that in the
November 23rd statement if people get to
November Tobias you're an estate agent
just explain in real terms I was saying
it earlier how difficult you've seen in
that introduction all these mortgage
companies that are pulling mortgages buy
to let gone first time buyers almost
impossible how difficult is it now for
people to get on that property ladder
the thing is the thing that the thing
that's unfortunate is that you've
obviously got the stamp Duty Cuts right
so that's that's to incentivize more
people to the market but nobody can get
mortgages right and so what is going to
make that difficult is that that's now
going to filter down to the tenants
these um these varying mortgage rates
are going to be passed on to the tenants
from the landlords and make their lives
difficult so people that are trying to
get onto the market are going to be
faced with difficulties they were given
an advantage with the stamp Duty Cuts
but almost a double-edged sword with the
um with the uh with the mortgage rates
right so it's now increasingly more
difficult for locals to be able to
purchase I mean we've seen how the pound
is faring against the Euro and the
dollar so this is going to incentivize
overseas
um property buyers it's not going to be
fair for the for people that are based
here Marina when I you know we'd
probably disagree politically in the
past but I I'm so wound up about what
seems to be
badly thought I find myself 22 days in
thinking whether this lady is up to
being the prime minister of the United
Kingdom
absolutely not and what we've seen with
this trust is she is um
she is basically the puppet to Puppet
Masters and at the moment she is if you
look at the people she's installing in
her government who are ERG who are all
these people that are linked to from you
know these think tax like yours and
there have been am I wrong there have
been question marks over your funding
and the motivations behind your
philosophies this is who Liz truss is
now listening to and this is sadly where
we are ending up are you a puppet master
no so the people
I mean people who support free market
ideas are there not links to fossil fuel
Industries
there are links between large
corporations and think tanks across the
Spectrum in fact I used to fund think
tanks including left-wing think tanks
when I was in the sector why might a
fossil fuel fund the iea what are they
expecting in return when I used to fund
the ippr which has affected the
Counterpoint to the iea on the center
left
about what you're doing now the IAA
I'm sure you don't want to talk about
how think tanks actually works no
because I know there are some really
good ones and those are the ones that
are very clear and transparent about
their funding the iea has been called
opaque in its funding because of its
links and it's very suspicious and the
fact is you are very much you just told
me you know who funds us and now you'll
say we're opaque there are links do you
think your advice from the eye or part
of your advice because you said there
are only certain things you agree with
do you understand the damage that that
top rape tax cut is going to make to
people's lives this government's success
is going to be based on this there are
many people saying the Tories have blown
it after 12 years and labor is quietly
marching to power that's what we want to
know rather than you say we didn't say
that we didn't say a lot of you believe
that these tax cuts they are not helping
the people who need it that's my problem
Andy do you agree with me there
so I agree with you to the extent that
the government has made a complete hash
of the communication of what they're
trying to do so it doesn't harm people
to cut down so you agree with the
substance do you think they didn't
describe it very well it doesn't harm
people to cut taxes Jeremy it harms
people if the government hasn't done
enough to help people across the board
how would you have helped people across
the board because two ways earlier one
was have been lifting the allowances
which have helped everybody and the
other would have been cutting vat
um Tobias what does sorry very quickly
device what does the estate agency
business the housing market what does it
need from this government it is it needs
people looked after you know people
everything is increasing mortgage rates
the cost of living rents you know you're
going to find a lot of people that are
having to shack up together going moving
back home they're not going to be able
to afford their rents they're saying
that house prices could drop by 10 in a
year
this is something that's being
speculated you know because I I actually
don't want to sit here every night and
think oh my God oh my God but but it was
hard enough during the summer talking
about the cost of living crisis this is
getting worse isn't it it is getting
worse and if you look now at the amount
of money that we're borrowing and the
cost of borrowing what it looks like and
we're going to hear about this in eight
weeks because the government have been
forced into revealing how they're going
to fund all this borrowing it's going to
come from welfare cutbacks and it's
going to come from cuts to services like
the NHS like can you believe that is
what we're going to be doing at this
time when we should be investing and
again Andy am I wrong this is part of
your philosophy IA it is all about small
state it's all about not putting money
into the services not putting money into
welfare so this is like your dream come
true
so a health on the health service for
example which is the main example of the
biggest areas of public spending the
view of the free marketers is not they
put less money into Health just putting
people put more of their own money into
Health as a mixed service like you have
across the whole of Continental Europe
not the U.S system which is far less
Equitable I think this is the end of the
Tory government
I don't know I mean it's very early days
it's clearly an enormous blow to their
morale to have this number of crises
impact them so soon into the new
Administration but it is part of the
two-year period so who knows what it's
going to be like in two years time I
mean you can say one thing about it I
thought she might spend two years
buttering up to the British election and
attempt to get uh re-elected I would
think in 22 days she's managed to turn
most people against her I sit here
thinking Boris Johnson didn't do such a
bad job did he
she's laughing now well Boris Johnson
obviously didn't uh lose his position as
a result of the economic circumstances
he lost it as a result of the personal
decisions he took during the pandemic
and that's an entirely different matter
but the big issue in the Tory leadership
election was Rishi sunak saying I'm
going to raise taxes versus this trust
saying I'm going to cut them and that's
what she's done
so that's a decision that was taken you
need the government to help for your
industry Marina do you think there's any
way back for the tourists to finish
quickly I really don't think so I really
hope not I think people are starting to
see them for what they are which is
they're basically now a cabal they have
become more and more incompetent and we
are just left this little cess pit of
talentless people who are just
protecting the interest of the 0.01 and
people are seeing through it now
something must be happening to me I
might be agreeing with you thank you all
very much indeed Andy Tobias Marina
thank you for coming up next after two
men were arrested as part of a cash for
honors Scandal involving our new king we
ask is he Above the Law and has Strictly
Come Dancing become a massive tick
blocking but I can't say that I tried
all day take boxing exercises it's very
difficult the BBC don't get excited
about the baby I'll be debating if it
has become so woke it's unwatchable next
on Piers Morgan uncensored we're coming
right back
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Jeremy Carl now as King Charles takes up
his new role new details are coming to
light about his managerial style as
Prince of Wales apparently we read today
he's a tough boss with a proper temper
and would phone staff at odd ass to
perform tasks such as sourcing an orchid
that tickled his fancy and of course we
all saw his angry side over pengate
oh God
[Music]
happens every stinking time uh but it
gets worse uh with two men being
questioned under caution by officers
investigating cash for honors
allegations linked to King's Charles
charity the prince's Foundation it's not
looking great for the Monarch in his
first few weeks on the job Johnny man
has to discussed this is talk to the
legend Kevin O'Sullivan the Queen
Elizabeth formed press actually good
friend of mine Dickie arbutter and Daily
Mirror associate editor Kevin McGuire
let's start with you Dicky if we can I
thought you would you would say so he's
got a temper
George V out of Temple George the sixth
out of Temple the queen had a temple
Charles has got a temper William's got
it they've all got it did any of them
ever take money in a plastic bag from
Saudi Arabia become on the money that
that you know you know I'm a royalist
okay isn't that a good look for a no
it's for a monarch to accept in and you
know that story is relevant yeah but
according to the charity Commissioners
he did nothing wrong they're all
collecting money all the charges are
collecting money rattling Tins in the
street they're collecting tens of
thousands it's cash okay excuse me they
say he got a bag of money he didn't do
anything wrong you know these two people
they've questioned Dickie would one of
them be faucet do we think that that
probably the former right-hand man is is
faucet I mean we don't know if that's
true that's an alleged comment of course
but here's the thing that I find quite
interesting forced it and he were
inseparable is is force it gonna keep
quiet out of loyalty or is he going to
spill his guts do you think because he's
been thrown out royally well he has been
thrown out he was forced to resign
because he was involved in the in the
cash for honors Scandal I mean how he
how he got there in the first place
because he's not in a position to offer
uh honors only uh the government can
issue on us in certain quarters on the
other hand the queen is used to issue on
us which the king can now do but it has
to be on the recommendation of The
Sovereign do you think
um that uh Kevin that Charles's judgment
has been called into into doubt because
of Fawcett because of you know money in
bags or do you think this is just the
people who are anti the monarchy the
Republican arm of the United Kingdom
will do nothing Maguire will do anything
to get rid of Matt bear in mind just how
amazingly popular monarchy is after the
last couple of weeks well the queen was
we'll see whether part of the monarchy
died with her and if he is as popular
but he was take in the charity tin for
the rich because he was living in some
of the properties that were being done
with his cash
the money the bag was the Qatari
controlled it the Saudi is alleged to
have been offered help to get an honor
and citizenship and other favors and had
a forest named after him at the castle
of May in gratitude by Prince Charles
this is not good and it's why I think
the whole hereditary principle and the
succession being immediate this couldn't
be investigated and scrutinized before
he got the job anybody else go for a job
in public life this was hanging over you
these allegations are made you would be
put on hold you would not be confirmed
in your post until it was cleared up and
there he is he's sitting tight now he's
got the top job and the police are
investigating his business dealings they
did say at the time that he personally
had done nothing wrong Kev Mark II is
this is I mean you're a royalist like me
it is it bad judgment is it the
Republican stirring up a horn it's Nest
had to see it I think that Prince
Charles as he was then showed appalling
judgment a serial number of times these
sacks full of cash as Dicky quite
rightly says not criminal but a terrible
terrible look the cash for honors it
should never have been involved in that
uh he's got himself into some serious
scrapes and the police May well have to
interview the monarch of this land and
that is how does that work that is bad
however however I wish him well uh I
hope he can control his temper uh and he
needs to I don't like his ideas about a
smaller monarchy I don't like his ideas
about Amiga little coronation we want
Majesty from the royal family we want
the kind of spectacle we saw at the
funeral we want that for the coronation
so I'm not sure he has the right ideas
but but I wish him well but one of his
staff was involved with cash for runners
he personally wasn't involved force it
if it was him was not in a position to
offer honors but then you have Dickie
and you know I agree with you but then
but then I bring you back to my favorite
subject Boris Johnson had to go but it
was all the people in Downing Street why
did he have to go then does the main man
not have to take responsibility I guess
is the question the main man only takes
responsibility if he knows that that is
right his person is doing look I worked
for him for five years I didn't tell him
everything I was doing I was told to get
on with the job and I got on with a job
if I needed to know something then I
would phone him but cash for owners
that was a rogue employee going off on
his own allegedly enforcer is right hand
man bad judgment to have him as his
right hand man but interestingly Michael
Fawcett Dickey has had to resign three
exactly well there's the argument if if
Charles and apparently I don't know
you'd know more than me apparently it
was Camilla who said you are going to
ruin your your coronation and everything
that's going to happen unless you get
rid of this bloke because this is the
third time that that they're in and
we're both stories that isn't great
judge the first two times he was fired
oh was he he was fired within the
household he was doing how did he get
back then he got back because he was out
of the household he was running the
charity The Man Who Knew Too Much yeah
yeah
that was bad judgment for Prince Charles
to have this guy back in the fall family
there what a family you have Andrew who
pays 12 million pounds to keep a sex
case out of court you got Harry making
all sorts of uh accusations with his
wife that they're they're racist and
pretty deplorable and now you've got
Charles don't get me started
now you've got Charles I thought who
through his foundation as a police
investigation I must say when I read
this and Dicky knows this the old man
worked for the royal family 41 years I'm
a royalist the the last thing the old
man ever said to me was Bloody pen he
didn't say that he said I fear that the
monarchy will never be the same after
the Queen the queen transcended I said
this the other day she transcended I
think almost every part of this country
religion color Creed background social
class because she was this stoic unbelie
you know you said Dickie very honestly
she had a temper I never saw her in 70
well I wasn't in life I've never seen
her on day three of course it's a stupid
pen she was this amazing woman she
admitted did she not she made one
mistake at the Abba fan thing in in
Wales but but actually
the monarchy has changed hasn't it we
know more than we ever did before don't
we well yes I mean this is Charles's uh
predicament I mean he's had to live his
whole life in the spotlight yeah uh the
royal family have had it to adapt to the
media and funnily enough I think the
queen was much better at adapting to
this New Media control world than Prince
Charles and King Charles now there is
this sort of aspect to King Charles that
he's he's like a figure from the past
you know a very a Regal character who
snaps at his staff and gets annoyed with
pens you know get that pen sorted out
for me uh something there's something
anachronistic about him and he's got to
raise his game in that respect but as I
keep saying I wish him well and I do
think he's a decent man all of the
problems he's got in to with these sacks
of cash he was just trying to raise
money for charity uh but bad well he was
good
what do you think he's doing taking it
for himself he wasn't taking it for
himself
no yes he did
that's why that's why he's got a forest
that Saudi guy's got a forest named yes
you're making allegations that he is
renovating buildings that he lived in
his building it was it's if you're
really Posh and you've got a load of
money and you're innocent people off you
can have foundations and you can say
this building isn't a found in a
foundation most of us just buy our homes
and we own them and that not anymore
to sell our houses we can't buy a house
we can't rent anywhere but I think
Jeremy will find that he's protected
from all that money
he doesn't even pay inheritance taxes
when you saw the outpouring of grief
when you saw the British public do what
they did right yeah does that not make
you think of the British public support
the monarchy serious question they
supported the queen certainly
unquestionably because they could uh no
I didn't I caught the end of it in St
George's uh I thought the queue was
impressive and people wanted to pay them
and I'm a respect
when he arrived at Buckingham Palace
first time there was Applause for him
there was chairs for him he went in on a
walkabout a woman pulled him forward to
give him a kiss on the cheek no
Protection Officer pulled her away the
people enjoyed it he stopped his car the
following day in the mouth didn't
approach the people who went in the
ground running the people the people
they were his supporters it's like same
oh no
you can't say anything
that the initial signs aren't that the
public support King Charles because they
just do and he's played a Blinder ever
since he took over
involving the people as you said she's
very interesting any Monarch nowadays I
I suspect you're right the
accountability in the scrutiny is far
greater than the queen I don't think
anybody will ever Follow The Queen I
think it's it's like trying to follow
this is a ridiculous analogy forgive me
for Alex Ferguson at Manchester United
it's just not possible was it I think
the queen transcended everything and
give Charles a chance I think that's
what we're saying I agree fantastic
thank you gentlemen right next tonight
here's a question for you a Strictly
Come Dancing becomes so woke it's
unwatchable I'll debating that uh
whether that show is all about inclusion
and no more is it about entertainment
we're coming right back in three don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I walk about my friends so Strictly Come
Dancing was once the staple of Saturday
night TV with over 10 million people
tuning in every week but there are now
claims that it's become a box ticking
exercise I said it and has become so
woke it's unwatchable from having
same-sex couples with absolutely zero
chemistry to paralympic Champion Ellie
Simmons who has knocked down barriers
the whole life but how will the Show's
first contestant with dwarfism be able
to perform dances like the tango and the
waltz when a dance partner is twice the
size and look what they've done to Craig
Revel horwood the judge famed for
tearing celebrities to pieces for a
single misstep has suddenly gone really
soft watch this disappointing
your upper body needs work and you also
with all the steps were sort of there
sometimes but um but they need to be
danced with a little bit more ease and I
think that's what Shirley means you know
with the breathing but I think you did a
really really great job thank you oh God
he's gone beige as well right joining me
is former strictly professional dancer
AJ Pritchard apparently he's older than
his brother Curtis who dances the Irish
version of the show and talk TV lesson
Kev who's obsessed with strictly oh I
love right let's start with a mission
and I don't want anybody to think badly
of me I've never seen one
I feel badly right now because it's an
awesome show it's so good to Win It
Court no he's a Serial semi-final but
it's a core program for the British
Community everybody loves and it's
across the world now it's franchised
over to 50 different countries now it's
so you were on the English one right yes
a new weren't I was on the Irish version
yeah that's not as good as the English
one is it it's a smaller base watching
it so you could say that in viewing
figures sir okay but they've gone woke
well I used to have to watch uh strictly
every week because I in another life I
was a TV critician yeah
the point is I respect the fact it was a
great show that millions of people
absolutely love and the BBC have turned
it into a sort of woke Fest uh with
single uh sex couples uh we've got Ellie
now with dwarfism they're very proud of
that now that's fine BBC want to do that
they should ask themselves is that what
the audience wants because in my day
when I used to have to watch it the
launch show would get 15 million uh this
launch show just now got uh just over
six million see it's it's not because
the audience seem to be saying nothing
well here's the question and I will bash
the BBC every single day of my life is
here's what I'm going to say to you what
he's trying to say is this have they
taken a program that that appealed to
everybody across every social barrier
right and gone oh it's really important
we don't upset them and we promote this
and prevent it are the BBC doing what
the BBC are great at in telling us all
what we should think and what's right
and what's wrong rather than just
letting us watch your projects I had you
said they're proud of it they're proud
show the diversity they're proud to be
inclusive and I think that's a really
positive thing this day
I think more we wouldn't be happy the
popularity is dropped because they're
getting rid of the core Pros no they're
not they're instructor the popularity is
drunk because people are watching talk
yeah I've gone and they had the biggest
fan base they became bigger maybe
because there's also a problem with the
recognition factor of the celebrities in
this series I mean I haven't heard of
hardly any of them so there's a problem
with that I take your point about the
pro dancers we've lost a lot of the
famous ones there but Alison Pearson got
it right she said you know that she
still sort of enjoys the show but she
dates back to when it wasn't like this
and she said that watching strictly now
oh somebody's sorry I do apologize
that's really embarrassing oh is that'd
be
fun
spandex me I don't think so I think you
would bring more of the viewers back
that's for sure it's it's a format that
people know we're British we like and we
know what we like
because they know what they're going to
get brilliant yeah but but this is
different to what they used to get and
it's getting smaller audiences much
smaller audience why Alison Alison
Pearson in the telegraph put it
perfectly she said it's like being
smashed over the head with a woke Mallet
uh and the question is I have no problem
good luck to the same sex couples really
good luck to Ellie and good luck to the
BBC if that's what they want to do but
there's an old phrase go woke and you go
bro
it's the change of the dancers they need
to keep the dancers traditional this is
what they need to do we love boring
Latin dances Strictly Come Together in
Britain that's what the standard foxtrot
Venus what's Quick Step Char Samba Rumba
passoji wow traditional dances what we
love we've added all of these other
things and I think this is what the core
audience don't like about it not because
that it this is like McDonald's the show
is it's a perfect recipe they don't need
to change it they can change it
with respect that is exactly what he's
saying
they have taken something that's worked
as long as it's worked for are they now
trying to still continues to work
politically it's not not working the
viewing audience
everything is not working my Instagram's
not working numerically when you put so
much content out there so many streaming
services so many different new TV shows
you're gonna spread it across other
people like it's not going to be exactly
the same at the end of the day it's an
audience that builds throughout the year
when it gets the final you're gonna have
that audience to come back around the
Winter's coming in it's setting in you
never get an awesome like rating
straight away these shows build because
you find people that you start to enjoy
you don't know some of the people on
there you've quite clearly said that but
people want to know people want to in
it'd be nice if they knew them in the
first place it is supposed to be a
celebrity I agree with you there at one
point but definitely you don't know
everybody we all come from different
backgrounds we have different interests
we watch different TV shows so why not
bring it all together what about the
other point at the end what about the
point is we go around and circles the
point is why take a product that works
why take a product that appeals across
the board and try and tick all the boxes
that nowadays every single damn TV
station and channels seem to do to make
things appeal to everybody and end up
missing the point end up missing what
you achieved at the first point which is
a people
whether you're male female female
however you dance together if it's man
man woman woman or whatever it is dances
dance is a follower and a leader it
doesn't so much so matter about that so
let me get let me go back to the
beginning because I know where you
you're on that celebrity SAS thing yes
I've watched that you've got cenome yeah
so how's how's career going any more
acting
Kurt loves the actors
acting from it I know I had a little bit
of a bad experience on hollyoaks and
stuff but I fell in love with it and
I've continued doing it
hello it is yeah
I'll be back again I have to say have we
got that clip I mean I love these boys
if you are at home dreaming of making it
on television and acting capacity please
watch this closely and never follow it
what
if we're going down
[Music]
Trish's little black book everything we
need star on dance school she's finished
how did you get it
I have my moves
please
[Laughter]
taking it the words
100 million times occurs in India like
it went viral it went viral they've
never had something
what do you think of your acting ability
do you imagine the Hollywood film
beckons after I says did you win SAS
well you're gonna have to watch that
says he said something that's quite
interesting my brother is a Serial
semi-finalist oh you did one thing
coming back to strictly that I do have
to say yeah the viewing audience they're
gonna vote for who they want to stay yep
at the end of the day we'll see who they
want to win and that's really
interesting
Ellie she will win I think that and the
audience will not be as big as
previously I think it's very interesting
the problem I'm only here because we can
come back and do that anyway
excuse me I'm on here because Piers
Morgan's playing golf right for two days
at the Dunhill links can you imagine
Morgan on on Strictly can you imagine
him in Spandex and a fake
I wouldn't do that but I'm thinking
would you be in the same sex dance with
Giovanni because I have to say something
he looks as uncomfortable as anything
Giovanni he does a little chemistry
though isn't it I don't think they'd put
two Pros together I think they'd win the
show it's kind of the snow that I'd be
put in who's the best pro ever to have
danced on Strictly Come Dancing I'm
gonna have to say on Strictly it was
possibly you way down
yeah
it did go on there and you got the most
followers the most the most talked about
the most Fame instantly from it do you
want to talk about what this is impacted
in your life the fact that your brother
seems to beat you and everything
[Laughter]
my wife and I were watching the SS and I
went oh bless him he's been sent home to
be fair I um I do uh people please a lot
and I like to help a lot of people so um
I think I shot myself in my foot in the
SAS I thought you were very very young I
thought you know really smug by the way
well your brother went are you really
upset well you know I was upset they
edited the part when I was crying and
saying listening I am not gonna Waltz
out of here because I can't dance an
absolute pleasure Kev thank you so much
and and the Pritchard Brothers the gold
medalist and the also rabbit
it's okay good luck with everything
thank you so much to Dean by the way so
just to repeat uh only here because
Piers Morgan's playing golf facts and
it's not funny apparently he played five
holes this morning and fell down through
them uh that's it for me whatever you
have to make sure it's uncensored have a
great night we're back here tonight from
right
foreign
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight show at all radio in the early
days the night of the brexit referendum
and that was actually quite a milestone
because of course we started off
thinking
um that remained had won and at half
past two quarter three after Nigel
farage had already said he'd lost it
turned out he hadn't lost it turned out
we were leaving the European Union so
that was quite a shocking
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Zora Suleman Liz truss
says she's standing by the chancellor
after his mini budget saw the bank of
England take drastic steps to stabilize
the economy the bank says it stepped
into Stave off what it called material
risk to the UK's Financial stability
amid reports Pension funds could have
collapsed today without the bank's
intervention well it comes as the labor
leader zakira starmer told talktv that
Parliament should be recalled because
the government has lost control of the
economy
Danish authorities say they expect the
nordstream one and two pipelines which
Supply gas to Europe to be empty by
Sunday they've been badly damaged in
what's widely thought to be Russian
sabotage
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]